اه دولت هدى استاذ
الاعلى ايه الله علي الخامنائي السلطات
الايرانيه التي يتزحمها خالها وضعت في
فيديو مصور الحكومات الاجنبيه الى قطع
علاقاتها مع السلطات بلادها
كف عن دعم هذا النظام المجرم وقاتل
للاطفال
الدينيه ولا يعرف اي قانون او حكم سوى
القوه والحفاظ على السلطه باي ثمن
يوم الاربعاء الماضي
وسجلت عندما توجهت الى مكتب المدعي العام
لتسليم امر قضائي انتقاد النظام الايراني
من اقرب المقربين ليس بالامر الجديده على
غرار ابنه الرئيس الراحل اكبر هاشمي رفسا
جاني يعتبر والد مراد خاني من اشد
المعارضين للقياده الدينيه الايرانيه بعد
وفاه الخميني عاده الاسره من منفاه في
العراق حيث عاشت 20 عاما وتولد فريده
امراه خان السيره على خطى والدها فطم
اعتقالها مطلع هذا العام واخلي سبيلها
بكفله بسبب مناهضتها لعقوبه الاعدام في
ايران